l'amérique en état de guerre et comme
forme de mobilisation c'est d'abord de
la guerre des images la censure semble
s'exprimer en empêchant la diffusion par
les chaînes de télévision des images des
victimes d' images sanglantes
une hypothèse que nous démontrer la
nuque et ludovic tourte près de 5000
morts mais une seule image publique
devant le pentagone pour en attester
plus de 2000 blessés mais un seul visage
ensanglanté
sous les débris du world trade center
sous l'épais nuage de poussière et de
gravats
la tragédie humaine n'est pas visible
l'amérique a fait le choix de ne pas la
montrer
là il faut dire qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures dans l'espace depuis l'heure à
laquelle on assiste actuellement qu'est
le web avec d'autres situations de
guerre ou de guerre civile ou de
génocide je pense par exemple au rwanda
où il a hélas avait pas la même présence
médiatique est pas la même souci de
respect des populations donc l'occident
doit faire attention au fait que pour
lui-même il fait très attention
et quand ils couvrent d'autres d'autres
tragédies du monde il est là c'est
beaucoup moins pudique sans pudeur
pourtant l'information est dit
il y à 94 corps et 70 morceaux de corps
je suis désolé d'avoir à décrire les
choses ainsi mais c'est malheureusement
ainsi qu'elles sont mais derrière les
mots derrière les images d'ambulances
hurlantes
il faut imaginer de l'hôpital on ne
verra que l'amérique solidaire celle qui
donne son sang
le seul blessé présentait aux caméras de
télévision est un policier rescapés
extraits des décombres plusieurs heures
après le drame
il y à une quarantaine d'années lorsque
les états unis étaient impliqués dans la
guerre du vietnam et que c'était la
première guerre qui fut télévisée on a
en effet eu beaucoup d' images sur
lesquelles des houches funéraires
étaient utilisés pour transporter les
cadavres de soldats
ces images ont traumatisé les américains
en 91 dans le golfe
les américains avaient voulu donner
l'image d'une guerre propre pour
conserver le soutien de la population
dix ans plus tard c'est aussi pour ne
pas la démoraliser qu'on lui épargne
l'horreur